una reunión crucial para el futuro de la
economía estadounidense el presidente
Joe biden recibirá Este martes en la
oficina oval a cuatro líderes del
Congreso
torrepublicanos y dos demócratas para
buscar acuerdos que permitan Elevar el
techo de deuda el departamento del
tesoro ha sido enfático o el congreso
eleva el límite de endeudamiento o el
Gobierno Federal se quedará sin fondos
para pagar sus facturas a partir del
primero de junio
es tarea del Congreso a probarlo si no
lo hacen Tendremos una catástrofe
económica y financiera que será ahora
nuestra
y no hay ninguna medida que el
presidente biden y el tesoro puedan
tomar para evitarlo
el debate legislativo se ha complicado
por las exigencias de Lala republicana
que acepta subir este tope con la
condición de reducir drásticamente el
gasto público pero el gobierno es Claro
en que no piensa dar su brazo a torcer
no debería haber negociaciones sobre el
límite de deuda Esto es algo sobre lo
que debería ponerse en orden y empezar a
trabajar No deberíamos tener a los
republicanos fabricando una crisis sobre
algo que se ha hecho 78 veces desde 1960
es su deber constitucional y el congreso
debe actuar
el techo de la deuda es una norma que
Define el monto límite que el gobierno
puede conseguir para pagar sus cuentas
unos 31,4 billones de dólares para esta
vigencia este tope se alcanzó en enero
cuando el departamento del tesoro
expidió medidas extraordinarias para dar
liquidez al gobierno mientras se llegaba
a un acuerdo en el congreso sin un
acuerdo Estados Unidos caería en el
primer impago de su historia un
escenario que de concretarse dejaría sin
ingresos a empleados federales militares
y pensionistas además de tener efectos
potencialmente catastróficos en la
economía global